the Devon building control partnership
is a shared service across three
authorities we check all types of
building works across the district's to
make sure it meets reasonable standards
contained in the building regulations
which are produced and regularly updated
by central government our surveyors
ensure the health and safety of people
in and about buildings we check that
they are structurally sound and will not
fall down we make sure there are
suitable fire precautions for example
fire escapes and a system of smoke
detection we make sure there is
reasonable access for all people with
disabilities the sick the young and the
old we look for buildings to be
sustainable and thermally efficient and
encourage reduced energy usage in order
to limit the production of co2 one of
the primary causes of climate change the
costs are made against the individuals
for their applications and do not come
from council tax building control also
deal with the council's responsibility
for dangerous structures for example
when there has been a fire or other
catastrophic event which may lead to
buildings becoming unstable by the way
we don't do planning permissions